partout en france en métropole comme en
outre-mer je vois à quel point à force
de renoncements et d'immobilisme
françois hollande et emmanuel macron ou
abîmés notre pays il est devenu urgent
de réparer la france
je suis candidate à la présidence de la
république pour restaurer notre pays
malgré l'ampleur du chantier qui devant
nous je ne me résous jamais au déclin je
suis une optimiste et surtout je suis
une volontariste j'ai les remèdes avec
un projet de société travaille et
audacieux radical un projet de franche
rupture et de droite assumé pour
défendre notre civilisation face à ceux
qui veulent la détruire remettre de
l'ordre dans la rue et dans les comptes
redonner de l'activité de la liberté et
de la fierté à chaque français
j'ai aussi le caractère non je n'aurais
pas la main qui tremble à partir du mois
de décembre les vraies difficultés
commencent il va falloir batailler dur
face à un président caméléon et des
extrêmes particulièrement
j'ai une volonté de faire une énergie
infatigable je ne lâche jamais rien
alors je me présente à vous aujourd'hui
avec cette promesse
ensemble nous allons faire gagner la
france
[Musique]